The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In the previous lectures, we
considered the general
continuum mechanics formulations
that we use for
nonlinear finite element
analysis.
And we also introduced briefly
the finite element matrices.
In the coming lectures, I would
like now to discuss with
you these finite element
matrices in more detail.
Finite element matrices can
generally be categorized as
continuum elements.
We call them sometimes
also solid elements.
The truss element, for
example, would
be a continuum element.
The 2D element, the
3D elements would
be continuum elements.
The 2D and 3D elements we may
also call solid elements.
And as another category, we have
the structural elements.
Structure elements are beam
elements, plate elements,
shell elements.
Of course, a distinguishing
feature between the structural
elements and the continuum
elements is that continuum
elements carry only nodal point
displacements as degrees
of freedom, whereas the
structural elements have also
rotational degrees of freedom
at their nodes.
In this lecture, I like to talk
about the 2D continuum
elements, the 2D plane stress,
plane strain, and
axisymmetric elements.
These elements are used very,
very widely in the engineering
professions for all sorts
of analyses--
plane stress analyses of plates,
plane strain analysis
all dams, axisymmetric analysis
of shells, and
so on and so on.
The elements are very general,
and can be used for geometric
and material nonlinear
analyses.
I also like to then, at the
end of the lecture, talk
briefly about the 3D elements
that are also very widely
used, and that are really
formulated in the same way as
the 2D elements.
Therefore, once you understand
to 2D elements very well, it
is fairly easy to generalize
these concepts or use these
concepts also to construct and
formulate 3D elements.
Let me now go over to my view
graph and discuss it with you
the information that I have
on these view graphs.
Once again, I like to talk
about plane stress, plane
strain elements, and
axisymmetric
elements in this lecture.
And these derivations that we
will be discussing, as I said
already, are directly applicable
also, or can
directly be extended to three
dimensional elements.
Let's look at a typical
2D element,
two dimensional element.
This is a nine-node element in
the stationary coordinate
frame, x1, x2.
x times 0, we would see
this element here.
Notice there are nine
nodes, 1 to 9.
Notice that we will be
talking about the
isoparametric elements.
And these have the R and F
auxiliary coordinate system,
the natural coordinate system,
just like in linear analysis.
X times 0, to the
element is here.
And at time t, the
Notice that the element has
undergone large displacements,
large rotations.
You don't see very large
rotations here, but the
rotations could be very large.
And certainly also
large strains.
You can see directly that the
element here has grown from
its size, so certainly
it must have been
subjected to large strains.
So we consider really a
very general motion.
But remember, once again, that
the coordinate frame, x1, x2,
the Cartesian coordinate frame,
remains stationary, as
we have discussed in the
previous lectures.
Because the elements are
isoparametric elements, we can
directly write these
expressions.
That 0x1's, the coordinates of
the material points in the
elements at time 0, are given
via this interpolation.
The hk are the interpolation
functions that we also use in
linear analysis.
The 0x1k are the nodal
point coordinates.
k refers to the nodal point.
1 refers to the coordinate
direction.
0 refers to the fact that
they're looking at the
configuration at time 0.
This 0 is, of course, the
same 0 that we see here.
This one is the same one
that we see there.
We are summing, of course,
of all the nodes.
And for the element that I just
had on the previous view
graph, it would be nine nodes,
so n is equal to 9.
We have a similar expression
for the
x2 coordinate direction.
In other words, 0x2 is
given like that.
This is the x2 coordinate of a
material particle, and it's
expressed in terms of the nodal
point coordinates of the
elements expressed in terms of
the nodal point coordinates of
the element.
The same expression is also
applicable at time t.
Notice all we have exchanged
is the 0 to a t, 0 to a t.
And similarly here for
the x2 coordinate.
0 to t, and similar
here, 0 to t.
Let us look at an example.
Here we have depicted
a four-node element.
The original element
lies here.
It's black.
The R and F system,
of course, is the
natural coordinate system.
This is a configuration of
the element at time 0.
It moves into that configuration
to time t, or it
is at, in this configuration,
at time t.
Notice that these are the
interpolations that I just
introduced you to.
The hk functions
are, of course,
interpolation functions.
Once again, these are here, the
nodal point coordinates.
k is the nodal point, t is the
time that we're looking at, xi
means the i's direction.
i, of course, in this particular
case, 1 or 2.
Similarly, for the original
geometry of the element.
The hk's are listed out here
on the right-hand side.
Notice these are the same
interpolation functions that
we are using in linear
analysis.
No difference there.
For example, h1 is
given right here.
And this is, of course, the
interpolation function
corresponding to nodal point
1, as shown right there.
You are probably very familiar
with these interpolation
functions, and I don't need
to go into details there.
But let us look now at the
following, namely what had
happened in the motion
to a nodal point.
A typical nodal point would be
the second nodal point here.
The original coordinates
are as shown.
And these original coordinates
have grown, or have become
larger as shown here, because
this node here has moved to
that new position.
Notice this is now here, the
coordinate of node 2, of
course, x1 coordinate.
This superscript 2 means node
2, this 1 means 1 direction.
t means time t.
Here we have 1 and
2 and time 0.
Notice here, 2, 2 times 0.
This 2 here, the bottom 2, means
coordinate direction 2.
This top 2 means
nodal point 2.
This is a convention that
we want to use.
It is a bit heavy, but we have
to somehow use a convention to
label our coordinates, and this
is the one that I chose
some time ago.
Similar here for the
2 coordinate, x2
coordinate, at time t.
tx2 at nodal point 2.
That upper 2, once again,
be the nodal point 2.
And of course, this would
also apply for all
the other nodal points.
If we look at the motion of a
material particle that is in
the element, we would obtain
that motion from the motion of
the nodal points.
Here we have now, in a nine-node
element that is
originality here, and moves
into this position.
At time t it is in
this position.
Let's look at one particular
particle within the element.
Here we have one particle
right there.
Notice that this particle
here is given via this
relationship here.
r and s are both 0.5--
you see r positive means this
direction, s positive means
that direction, r and
s 0.5 is there.
We would use r and s equal to
0.5, substitute into hk.
And then, of course, we have 9
such hk's, substitute r and s
equal to 0.5 into each
of these hk's.
And sum out, this right-hand
side, to get the coordinate,
the coordinates--
there are two, of course--
of this point here, this
material particle, at time 0.
That's how we would obtain
the coordinates of
that material particle.
Now, at time t, we proceed
much in the same way.
Here we have the equation.
We would, again, take hk at r
equal to 0.5, s equal to 0.5,
for all case, and multiply
these hk values by these
values here, which of course,
are given because we must know
where these nodal points
have arrived at.
So we can evaluate the
right-hand side to directly
get these two values, there are
two such values, tx1 and
tx2, which gives then the
position of this material
particle at time t.
Notice that the isoparametric
coordinates of a material
particle never change.
You put that here in red because
that is very important
to keep in mind.
Of course, the actual
coordinates of the particle
change, because that particle
moves through space in a
stationary coordinate
frame, x1 and x2.
But we are in s coordinates.
The natural coordinates
do not change.
Well a major advantage of the
isoparametric finite element
analysis is that we can directly
write, of course, at
the displacements, are given
as shown here via the nodal
point displacements.
tU1 is the displacement of
the material particle
into the one direction.
The hk's are the isoparametric
interpolation functions.
And these are the nodal
point displacements.
k being the nodal point
displacements
of nodal point k.
Similarly, for the
2 direction.
And this holds at time t, and
it also holds for the
incremental displacements from
time t to time t plus delta t,
as written right here.
That this is, in fact, 2 can
easily be shown from the
coordinate interpolations.
You see we had already these two
interpolations, and all we
need to do now is subtract on
the left-hand side, and on the
right-hand side, to obtain
this equation here.
And what are left with here,
of course, must be the
displacement of the material
particle that
we're looking at--
tUi.
And here, we must have
the displacement
of the nodal points.
And these are denoted as tUik.
And that is exactly the
relationships that we were
just dealing with, tUi
is equal to hk tUik.
There is one very important
point that I like to
point out to you.
Namely, that these equations
show directly that if we use a
finite element mesh that is
originally compatible, in
other words, compatible in a
linear analysis, than this
finite element mesh will remain
compatible throughout
the motion, throughout the
large deformation motion.
And that is a very
important point.
That we can say that the mesh
which originally is compatible
will remain compatible
throughout the analysis.
That follows directly from
these equations.
The element matrices that we
need, of course, require
derivatives, and these are
obtained much in the same way
as in linear analysis.
We need this derivative here,
partial tUi, with respect to
the original coordinates.
This is the actual derivative.
This is the abbreviation
that we used
in the earlier lectures.
And we obtained this derivative
by taking the
differentiation of the hk's with
respect to the original
coordinates.
Of course, these are numbers.
These are the nodal point
displacements.
So it's this one that we really
need to evaluate this
derivative.
Similarly, for the incremental
displacements.
We want to take the
differentiation of the
incremental displacement with
respect to the original
coordinates.
It's achieved this way.
Once again, here we have an
expression that we need to
evaluate, which also goes
in here, of course.
And as we evaluate, as we will
just now see, much in the same
way as in linear analysis.
Notice, here we have written
down the partial of Ui with
respect to the current
coordinates
obtained as given here.
Of course, these are the nodal
point displacement increments,
and here we have the
differentiation of the hk's
with respect to the current
coordinates now.
So once we have these evaluated,
these expressions
evaluated, we can obtain all
of the derivatives that go
into the strain displacement
matrices that we want to have
for the element.
The derivatives are evaluated
using the chain rule, just as
in linear analysis.
We are using that partial hk
with respect to r, is given as
partial hk with respect to x1
times partial x1 with respect
to r, et cetera.
Of course, these are here
the derivatives
that we want to calculate.
Notice, this is what we
need to calculate in
order to get these.
And these here, just like in
linear analysis, go into the
Jacobian matrix written
down here.
Here we have the Jacobian
matrix.
And this is what we want.
Therefore, we need to invert
the Jacobian matrix, as in
linear analysis.
And we obtain via this
relationship here, the
required derivatives.
The entries in this
matrix involve
derivatives of this form.
Partial x1, 0x1 with
respect to r, with
respect to s and so on.
And those are obtained here as
shown on the right-hand side.
Notice here, of course, we only
need differentiations
with respect to r, with
respect to the natural
coordinates.
And since the functions hk are
a function of r and f, we can
directly evaluate these kinds of
expressions that go in the
Jacobian matrix, and the
inverse, of course.
If we want to take derivatives
with respect to the current
coordinates, we proceed
much in the same way.
This is the relationship that
we arrive at by simply
substituting instead of the
0xi, the txi in to the
Jacobian matrix, and of course,
into the expressions
that are in here.
So here we have a Jacobian
matrix that is giving the
derivatives of the current
coordinates at time t with
respect to the natural
coordinates.
Such an element is obtained
as shown here.
It involves again only the
differentiation of the
interpolation functions with
respect to the natural
coordinates.
Here, of course with respect
to s, because we want to
differentiate with
respect to s.
Of course, these are the nodal
point coordinate at time t,
which are known.
We invert this relationship
here to obtain the
differentiation that
we need to have.
We are now ready to compute the
required element matrices
for the total Lagrangian
formulation.
And the element matrices that we
want to compute, of course,
our those established in
the early lectures.
The matrices that go into
evaluating these matrices are
listed here.
Here, of course, the tangent
constitutive relationship,
which we will talk
about much later.
Not in this lecture.
Here we have the linear strain
displacement matrix, the
nonlinear strain displacement
matrix.
Here again, the linear strain
displacement matrix, a stress
vector, and a stress matrix.
Let's see now how these matrices
look for the two
dimensional case.
The constitutive relation,
just very briefly--
again, much more detail will be
given in a later lecture--
would be relating the increment
in stress to the
increments in strain.
Notice there's a 2 here, and
this is the matrix which is
established from this
relationship here.
In the early lectures,
we used this
relationship, the tensor notation.
Well we have now a matrix
notation, and this is the
relationship with that
matrix notation.
C for a linear elastic material
would look as shown
here, and you are familiar with
this relationship from
linear analysis.
It's the same matrix that we
encounter in linear analysis.
Of course, e being Young's
modulus, nu
being Poisson's ratio.
We also derived in the early
lectures the expression for
the incremental strain terms.
And here they are listed out.
We have derived these right-hand
side expressions.
We notice that what is here
underscored by a blue line was
the initial displacement
effect.
And is this initial displacement
effect, of
course, is a particular in
gradient off the total
Lagrangian formulation,
as we discussed
in the early lectures.
The nonlinear strain terms that
we also derived in the
earlier lectures, are
listed here for the
two dimensional case.
We have seen all these
expressions on the earlier
view graph, except that we use
then additional notation, in
other words, a notation that
involved k and j's and i's,
and we have to sum over k.
Well if you do so, you directly
arrive at these
relationships here.
It's an interesting point to
derive this expression and the
linear strain part for the hoop
strain-- this is called
the hoop strain--
in the axisymmetric case.
And let us look at
that derivation
a bit more in detail.
Here we have an axisymmetric
element in its original
configuration.
At time 0 it has moved into this
configuration up to time
t plus delta t.
Since we want to get the
incremental strain from time t
to time t plus delta t, we're
looking at the configuration
of time t plus delta t
in this derivation.
Notice that this here is the
axis of revolution, which we
denote as x2, x1 is this axis.
And if we look as a plan view
onto this element, we would
see this x1, x2 coming out of
the view graph, and x3 going
down like this.
Notice this here we label as
0ds, the initial length of a
hoop fiber, so to say.
In fact, this hoop fiber starts
right there at 0x1,
which is, and I have to go now
upwards to the upper graph
again, which is nothing else
than the starting point of
that fiber.
In other words, this green dot,
this green dot is nothing
else than the start
of this arrow.
I could say let's line
them up like that.
So this arrow here goes really
into the view graph up there.
If you look further to the right
here we see that we have
also a blue arrow, of
course, curved.
We call it the hoop, it's a
circle really, the radius
around this origin that we're
looking at, like that.
And notice that the start of
this arrow here is this blue
dot right there.
A material fiber, a material
particle, let's put it this
way, a material particle that
has moved from here to there
causes, in axisymmetric
analysis, this fiber here to
take on this length.
And of course, the change
in this length
gives us the hoop strain.
Let us look at this relationship
here, because
that gives us a relationship
between the change in the
length of the fiber, green
fiber, blue fiber, so to say,
in plan view.
And that is nothing else than
0x1 dividing t plus delta x1.
Why is that the case?
Well you see it by geometry
from this picture.
And we will use this expression
here now to
evaluate the actual strain.
We find that the
Green-Lagrangian strain can be
written as in this form.
We substitute the expression
that we just obtained for this
relationship.
We substitute the
displacements.
Displacements to configuration
t, and incremental
displacement from t to t plus
delta t divided by the 0x1, of
course, still here.
We then go through a number of
steps of arithmetic, I'm sure
you can easily do those, and
you arrive at this result.
If we look at this, we find that
this here expression only
involves the displacements
to time t.
And that must, therefore,
be the Green-Lagrangian
strain at time t.
Notice that this expression
here involves incremental
displacements, linear
incremental displacement, no
products of them,
and the initial
displacement at time t.
This is the initial displacement
effect, which we
always have in the total
Lagrangian formulation.
This is a linear strain term
involving only the incremental
displacement.
And this the total linear
strain increment.
Notice this is a total nonlinear
strain incremental.
It involves the incremental
displacement u1 squared, and
that's why it is a nonlinear
strain increment.
Of course, this total here is
the incremental strain.
This total is the incremental
strain.
It's a nice derivation that
gives some insight into how
these expressions that I had
already on the earlier view
graph are arrived at.
Well we are now ready to
construct the B matrix.
On the left-hand side,
we would have,
of course, the strains.
If you look at the linear strain
displacement matrix, we
have the linear strains here.
Notice there's a 2 here because
of the 0e12 being
equal to 0e21.
We simply put 2 times
0e12 in here.
And this is a total linear
strain increment.
Here we have a sum of two
matrices giving us a total
linear strain displacement
matrix.
This is the one that does
not include the initial
displacement effect.
That one includes initial
And here we have the nodal point
incremental displacement
the way we defined them
in an earlier lecture.
Well the entries in t0BL0 are
shown here, involving of
course, four-nodal point
k derivatives of the
interpolation functions
corresponding
to nodal point k.
Notice that this last row is
only included if we are
dealing with an axisymmetric
analysis.
And notice that these are then
exactly the terms that we also
have in linear analysis.
So no surprises here.
No new entries, as a matter
of fact, when
compared to linear analysis.
Except that we see a 0 here,
meaning, of course, that we're
taking a differentiation with
respect to the original
coordinates.
Generally, in linear analysis,
if you look at the book, of
course, you would not see this
0 here because it's not
necessary to have
that 0 there.
We always take differentiations
with respect
to the original geometry.
Maybe a quick word also how
we want to read this here.
Notice these two entries here,
of course, nothing else in
these two blue entries.
Because these two entries
multiply these two columns,
for readability I put this entry
there, put this entry
there, so that you directly
see this column here
corresponds to u1k, and this
column corresponds to u2k.
Of course, both columns
correspond to node k.
If we look at the matrix t0BL1,
which includes now the
initial displacement effect,
in fact, introduces the
initial displacement effect to
the total strain displacement
matrix, it looks this way.
Once again, this is a
contribution coming
corresponding to u1k This
is the contribution
corresponding to u2k.
And notice here you have the
initial displacement effect
appearing right here.
All initial displacement
effects.
And similarly here, initial
displacement effect.
Once again, if you don't have
an axisymmetric analysis, in
other words, you have a plane
stress, plane strain case, you
would drop this last row.
We construct the t0BNL
and T0S matrix.
Next for the geometric stiffness
matrix, and we
talked about this expression in
the earlier lecture, notice
that this here is giving up, of
course, the matrix, the k
matrix, that we're looking
for, this part here.
And the F matrix looks
as shown here.
I pointed out very strongly in
the earlier lecture that we
construct the S and the BNL such
that when this product is
taken, we get directly
this one.
Because this is basic.
This is obtained from the
continuum mechanics
formulation.
And we want to evaluate this.
Therefore, we construct the
BNL and S such that this
product, indeed, gives
us this contribution.
And as is constructed
as shown here.
The BNL is constructed
Notice the u2k contributions,
the u1k
contribution for node k.
Finally, we also need the
t0S vector, hat vector.
I pointed out in the earlier
lecture that this vector and
this matrix are constructed in
such a way that this product
here gives us exactly this
expression here.
This is basic coming from
continuum mechanics, and this
is what we have to capture.
The entries in F hat
are given here.
And with this then, we would be
ready to actually calculate
all the matrices and vectors
for the total Lagrangian
formulation.
Let us now look at an example to
reinforce our understanding
of how all of these matrices
are constructed,
how they are evaluated.
Here we have the
following case.
A four-node element
originally in the
configuration shown in black.
Four nodes, as you can see,
one, two, three, four.
This element moves from time
0 to time t into this
configuration.
The RAD configuration.
Node 0.1 move there, node
0.2 move there.
Notice that the element has
stretched and sheared over,
but it has only stretched into
the vertical direction, not
into the horizontal direction.
Let us identify the lengths,
values that we
have to deal with.
0.2 here, 0.2 there.
Notice that the displacement
upward is 0.1.
And the shearing over,
so to say, is 0.1.
We want to consider plane
strain conditions.
And the problem that we like to
pose is calculate these two
matrices, the linear strain,
and the nonlinear strain
displacement matrix for
this particular case.
Let's first look now a bit at
what's happening here to the
material fiber.
If we look at the horizontal
material fiber, shown here in
black in the original
configuration, we notice that
these material fibers are simply
translated rigidly over
horizontally.
As shown here via
the red arrows.
So these black material fibers
lying horizontally are simply
sheared over rigidly, as shown
by the red arrows.
2 time t, of course.
Let's look now at the vertical
fibers in this problem.
Let's see what has
happened to them.
Here we have the vertical fiber
shown in black in the
original configuration.
Let's see how they end up in
their final configuration.
We see that these fibers have
actually stretched, they've
become longer, and they have
also rotated over.
Well this is the kinematics
that we are looking at.
And let us now attack the
problem of constructing, once
again, the linear strain
displacement matrix, and the
nonlinear strain displacement
matrix.
We do so by first identifying
which is the isoparametric
coordinate system that we use.
That coordinate system is
shown here, r and s.
Let us then now start
this problem.
And we identify simply by
inspection really because it's
a fairly simple geometry that
we're dealing with.
That this differentiation is
nothing else than 0.1, this
differentiation is 0, that one
is 0, and this one is 0.1.
Of course, these are the
elements that go into the
Jacobian matrix, as I
discussed earlier.
We put these elements into this
2 by 2 matrix, calculate
the determinant, interesting
to note what the value is.
That one is needed, of course,
later on in the numerical
integration of the matrices.
And we also recognize that to
obtain this derivative of an
interpolation function,
we need to
invert this matrix here.
This 0.1 inverted gives
us 10, and that is
this 10 right there.
Therefore, we have now partial
with respect to x1, 0x1 is 10
times partial with respect to
R. Of course, in the actual
expression, we would put hk's
in here, and hk's in there.
Similar we get the
differentiation
with respect to x2.
We will use this expression
here, putting the actual hk's
in there and in there.
Well this is some preparatory
work to actually complete the
problem of constructing the
linear strain and nonlinear
strain displacement matrix.
And I think this is actually
a very good point where you
might want to sit back and try
to complete the whole problem.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome again.
I hope you've had a close look
at the example, and surely I
would be very interested
in knowing how it went.
But let us now look
at the solution.
We already discussed that for
this example, the Jacobian is
given by this matrix here.
And therefore, these are the
differentiations that we can
directly use.
Notice, of course, we need the
differentiation with respect
to the x1 coordinate, and with
respect to the x2 coordinate
of all the interpolation
functions.
One way to proceed now is to
make a little table where we
have here in this column the
nodes, we have in this column
here the differentiations that
we need, partial hk with
respect to 0x1.
Further differentiations here,
partial hk with respect to x2.
Notice that the Jacobian, the
inverse of the Jacobian matrix
being 10, makes a 1/4
equal to 2.--
1/4 times 10 being
equal to 2.5.
So that's why you see
the 2.5 here.
These are the nodal point
displacements, which, of
course, are given for this
particular case.
And with these nodal point
displacements given, and these
differentiations calculated
as listed here, we can now
evaluate these products here.
And that is done as shown
in these columns.
Notice the sum of these gives
us these differentiations
here, which go into the initial
displacement effect of
the strain displacement
matrix.
Well like that, of course, you
can also calculate the
differentiations of the
t0u21 and the t0u22.
And both these terms are also
required in the initial
displacement effect of the
strain displacement matrix.
Another way to proceed, to get
this initial displacement
effect, is to evaluate the
deformation gradient.
In an earlier lecture, we talked
about the deformation
gradient and it's listed
right here.
It's a 2 by 2 matrix because
we're talking about a two
dimensional motion.
And here you have, for example,
partial tx2 with
respect to 0x1.
Here you have partial tx1
with respect to 0x1.
0x1, et cetera.
And if we take this deformation
gradient or the
elements of that information
gradient, we can directly
obtain these differentiations
here.
In other words, t0x11
minus 1 must give us
this expression here.
t0x12, being that one here,
gives us tu1 with respect to
0x2, in shorthand notation
written as
shown here, et cetera.
So we can obtain, in other
words, these elements also
from the deformation gradient.
Let us now look at how the
columns of the strain
displacement matrices look.
We simply substitute into the
general expressions that I
gave you earlier, and here we
have the t0 be a 0 entry for
node three.
Of course there are eight
columns altogether because we
have a four-node element.
We just showed two such
columns here for--
namely, those corresponding
to node three.
Similarly, for t0BL1, we
get these entries here.
Once again, also for node
three, of course.
Similarly, we can also construct
the corresponding
columns in the t0BNL matrix.
And these columns are
given right there.
Once again, for node three.
This is, of course, also a
matrix that have altogether
eight columns, because there are
four nodes, eight degrees
of freedom.
Let us now, as a next step,
consider the updated
Lagrangian formulation in the
general plane stress, plane
strain, axisymmetric case.
In the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we have
identified earlier, in an
earlier lecture, that we need
these matrices and
that vector.
This is, of course, a linear
strain stiffness matrix,
that's a nonlinear strain
stiffness matrix, and that is
the force vector that
corresponds to the internet
element stresses.
The matrices that go into the
calculation of these matrices
are listed here.
The tangent material
relationship, the linear
strain displacement
matrix go into the
calculation of this k matrix.
This stress matrix, and that
strain displacement matrix,
the nonlinear strain
displacement matrix, these two
quantities go into the
calculation of this k matrix.
And this stress vector,
and that linear strain
displacement matrix
goes into the
calculation of that F vector.
We already derived that all
earlier in an earlier lecture.
The stress strain matrix
is listed here.
Notice that we have the
incremental stresses.
Of course, these are increments
in the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses
from time t onwards.
That's why you have
the t here.
That's why this t corresponds,
of course, to the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
Here we have the material
tensor, here we have the
strain terms.
Once again, the 2 that I pointed
out early already for
the total Lagrangian
case as well.
Of course this matrix here,
contains the elements of the
material tensor, tCijrs, which
we used earlier when we talked
about the continuum mechanics
formations.
Well for the linear elastic
case, we would simply use the
very familiar stress strain law
that we are using also in
linear analysis.
Young's modulus, Poisson's
ratio.
So this is one typical case
for this C matrix.
Of course, we will discuss later
on in later lectures how
we construct the C matrix for
all sorts of material
conditions.
We need for the B matrix, for
the linear strain displacement
matrix, these entries here,
meaning we need these
differentiations.
Notice partial u1 with respect
to tx1 is in shorthand
notation written
as shown here.
te22 is equal to that element,
and similarly we go on.
Notice this, of course, is
again, the hoop strain.
For the nonlinear strain
displacement matrix, we need
to look at the nonlinear
strain terms.
And the nonlinear strain terms
are listed out here now.
We identified these strain
terms earlier when we
discussed the updated Lagrangian
formulation in an
earlier lecture.
Of course, at that time, the
strain terms were represented
in terms of ijk indices.
Now we have to simply put i and
j equal to 1, for example,
and k equal to 1, and equal to
2, and you will directly
obtain from the earlier
expression that I presented to
you this term here.
And similarly, you obtain all
the other terms as well.
By the way, the hoop strain,
the linear, and here we see
the nonlinear hoop strain,
expression would be derived in
the same way as we have done
it in this lecture for the
total Lagrangian formulation.
It would actually be a good
exercise for you to do so one
and see how that goes.
We construct the ttBL matrix to
capture the total strain,
total linear strain, listed in
this vector here as shown by
this equation.
Of course, here we have the
nodal point displacements.
The nodal point displacements
are in this vector.
Denote always that these are
the discrete nodal point
displacements.
This last term, of course,
we only introduced in
axisymmetric analysis.
The entries in this ttBL matrix
are shown here for a
typical node k.
We use the same kind of picture
as for the total
Lagrangian formulation.
Notice here are the actual
displacements, the way they
would appear in a vector.
But since this element here hits
this column so to say, we
have written it here
once more in blue.
This element here hits this
column, and we have therefore
written it here once
more in blue.
So this is really the column
corresponding to the case node
and the u1, the 1 direction.
This is the column corresponding
to the case node
and the 2 direction.
If you compare this matrix with
the matrix that we use in
linear analysis, you would see
that the matrix looks very
similar, except that in linear
analysis you would not have
this t, or you don't put that t
there in general because the
t would, of course, be actually
the 0 configuration
because all the differentiations
are referred
to 0 configuration anyway.
And it is common to not have
an index down here.
If you look at this textbook,
chapter five, you would, for
example, see there expressions
such as this
without this t there.
So there's really not much
of a surprise right here.
You will surely see that this
is the right relationship to
use in the B matrix
based on your
knowledge of linear analysis.
The expression of the nonlinear
strain displacement
matrix and the stress matrix are
these two expressions are
constructed in such a way as to
have that this product on
the left-hand side is equal
to that expression there.
I pointed that out already
earlier, that on the
right-hand side this is the
continuum mechanics variable,
and this continuum mechanics
variable is, of course, the
basic quantity, the basic
quantity that we actually want
to capture.
And we construct this matrix
and that matrix
such as to do so.
I should just point out there
should be no bar here.
Of course, this is a tensor
quantity, it's not a matrix,
and so there should
be no bar there.
That was a little error
on my part.
The entries in the t tau
are given right here.
The last row and column are,
of course, only included if
you deal with an axisymmetric
analysis.
ttBNL is shown here.
Notice again, differentiations
with respect to time t.
And the last row is only
included if you have an
axisymmetric analysis.
Finally, we want to also
construct our stress vector
such that when it is entered
here with the BL matrix that
we already have defined, we
capture via this product here
exactly that term.
This is the term that is basic,
that we have derived
from the continuum mechanics
formulation.
This is what we want to capture,
and we do so by this
expression.
And t tau hat is given
right here.
It lists all the stresses
really, including the hoop
stress if you have an
axisymmetric analysis.
This completes what I wanted
to say about the two
dimensional elements.
We talked about the total
Lagrangian formulation, and
the updated Lagrangian
formulation of these elements.
In other words, we really
presented the matrices
corresponding to these
formulations
in quite some detail.
These details that we discussed
for the two
dimensional elements are also
almost directly applicable for
the three dimensional
elements.
And here we have a typical
eight-node element in a
stationary coordinate frame,
x1, x2, x3, in its original
configuration.
The nodal point coordinates
are listed here.
Notice k, of course, stands
again for the node k.
1, 2, 3 stands for the
directions 1, 2, 3.
And the left superscript here
stands for the time 0, the
configuration 0.
The element moves from time
0 to time t up to this
configuration here.
And the nodal points
now are tx1k--
nodal point coordinate
I should have said.
Now tx1k, tx2k, tx3k.
The notation is much the same
as we have been using in two
dimensional analysis.
Of course, we now have a third
coordinate, the x3 coordinate
also in the formulation.
We now use interpolations much
the same way as for the two
dimensional elements.
For the original configuration,
we have these
interpolations.
Notice, the third direction
enters now.
Once again, these are the
interpolation functions.
These are the nodal point
coordinates corresponding to
the 1 direction.
These are the nodal point
coordinates corresponding to
the 2 direction, and so on.
Of course, we now also have to
introduce the nodal point
coordinates corresponding
to the 3 direction.
And if the number of nodes,
if you have an eight-node
element, and of course is 8.
These are the interpolations
used for the original geometry
of the element, and for the
configuration at time t, we
use these interpolations.
Notice these are now the nodal
points coordinates
corresponding to time t.
We use still the same
interpolation
functions, of course.
And N is the same number as for
the 0 interpolation, or
rather for the interpolation
of the original geometry.
In other words, for the
eight-node element that we
briefly considered, N is in
each case equal to 8.
We use these expressions, we
subtract from tx1 the 0x1 from
tx2, the 0x2 expression from
tx3, the 0x3 expression, and
directly obtain the
interpolations for the
displacement of the elements.
And once we have the
displacement interpolation,
we, of course, can directly find
the derivative of these
displacement interpolations
to obtain the strain
interpolations.
And these expressions then,
the derivatives of the
displacement interpolation,
enter into the construction of
the strain displacement
matrices.
So we see that basically, the
same procedure that we
discussed with two dimensional
analysis is directly
applicable to the three
dimensional analysis, the only
difference being that the third
direction, x3, has to be
interpolated, the displacements
have to be
carried along corresponding
to the third
direction, et cetera.
This then brings me to the end
of what I wanted to say in
this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.